halliburton the oil services company is
cutting six and a half to eight percent
of its global workforce this is
confirmed by the spokesperson at the
firm in an email to Bloomberg News there
are no layoffs plan due to the Baker
Hughes deal where it is merging with
that company but this is because of the
challenging market environment those
were the exact words used by the company
total headcount at Halliburton is
currently more than 80,000 we should
mention as well that the Houston
Business Journal earlier reported that
Halliburton will be cutting 5,000 to
6500 jobs and of course this comes as
oil prices have plunged more than fifty
percent from their highs in June of last
year if you look at how Halliburton
shares are performing in the wake of
this announcement take a look at the
Bloomberg terminal here this is the
intraday chart for Halliburton you can
see that we opened lower and have been
on a little bit of a recovery insofar as
we paired our declines and yet when this
news hit we hit our lows of the day down
two point eight percent at the moment at
42 27